and then the monkey just tears his
[__] scalp off [__] that not just
some strands of hair it just went
[__] ripped off I'm telling you don't
[__] with nature right that's why I
never want to go to those monkey
sanctuaries in Thailand oh [__] I keep
seeing videos of people trying to give
them food and they go [__] you I'm
taking your soul I'm not I'm taking your
baby have you seen that Monk on a
motorcycle dude in five four three two
one what's up everybody welcome to
another episode of The Genius brain
podcast I am your host David so and we
have Ed parkvp in the house once again
dude we just came back from a weekend of
UFC Extravaganza and the Super Bowl and
the Super Bowl which to be honest with
you I don't know yeah
like a killer [__] less about any of
those teams yeah
nobody really gave a [__] about the
Super Bowl this year but it was a great
game that's for sure it was a great game
um the commercials I don't really
remember I can't go at the top of my
head [__] uh what's it called
admirable ones the only thing that
people were talking about they didn't
even talk about the [__] game they're
just talking about Rihanna
she's pregnant right yeah okay so I
asked that right I was like hey she
pregnant and they're like no she had her
baby I was like oh I feel like an
[__] and then this morning it came
out she's pregnant again like okay and
everybody's like [__] we gotta wait
she's never gonna make an album dude
yeah she's pregnant again dude Riri baby
um we watched uh the UFC against mock it
was makachev versus uh volkanovsky which
was pretty [__] insane if you guys
aren't a fight fan
um pound for pound best fighter
volkanovsky is what they're saying yes
uh versus makachev who is supposed to be
this unbeatable robot the second coming
of khabib
which we saw today is not true
the other day
like
like I mean this is debatable but Habib
mauled his opponents right the amount of
significant strikes that were landed on
him was [__] nothing and makachev
I'll I think he just takes a lot more
risks but dude volkanoski's stock went
up yeah and a lot of people thought that
volkanoski win I won I don't think so
like uh I scored it did you see the
Rogan wait he did the fight company Joe
they're all like whoa yeah they all
thought he got robbed Joe Rogan all of
them were just like he got robbed we
everybody in the room are like no that
makes sense yeah like one two and four
was makachev three was debatably
volcanovskis and then five for sure
falconos right so I like I I don't know
like the I don't understand why people
thought it was
you know I think when people watch the
fight back again uh without the
excitement of him getting up from the
takedowns and stuff a lot of them
they'll be like oh okay I could see why
because makachev landed a lot more I
don't know the actual stats but he
rocked volkanovsky quite well from what
I saw visually or was it more
significant strikes I guess like once
again I have to re-watch it again but I
just saw volkanosis had snapped back a
lot more except for the fifth round so
if we're not judging this fight round by
round and it's just for the whole for
the fight in general yeah the vocal
NASCAR would have taken it in that fifth
round and the fight would have been done
but it's done round by round all right
so in that in that sense I believe that
makachev won uh three to two so I don't
even think it was that close I mean I
guess it is pretty close I mean it feels
good enough man they'll have a rematch
I'll get back into it I mean but he has
to go back down a featherweight to fight
yair Rodriguez dude how do you think
that's gonna turn out I think yeah right
against gonna lose I don't think anybody
beats volkanovski right so if you guys
just go up on YouTube tube if you're not
a fight fan just watch this little guy
he looks like a [__] troll from The
Lord of the Rings like five six yeah but
walks around 170. 170 180 his arms like
the same wingspan as mine and I'm just
one yeah so he looks [__] weird as
the caveman yeah he's a [__] kid he's
a knuckle Dragon yeah that's basically
Joe Rogan if he was here
without the bloated chest yeah and then
you have Islam which makachev is uh from
Dagestan yeah and for those people who
aren't fight fans once again Dagestan is
known to have these amazing uh [__]
practitioners which is their version of
like grappling and wrestling
and he has just been Untouchable so the
idea behind this fight was that
volkanovsky who was the underdog was
just going to get mauled and his
wrestling wasn't going to be good enough
volganovsky's strength is unreal I mean
he still wasn't getting the better of
makachev during those grappling
exchanges but it was a stalemate on the
ground for most part yeah yeah yeah yeah
so volkanoski is somebody he's just so
different so if you're going to
if you look back at voknowski beating
like Max Holloway he beat him three
times uh arguably two of them I don't
think that volcanoski won the first two
I feel still to this day watching the
fights back that he lost both those
fights yeah and then he just continually
upgraded from every time he got to meet
Max to the third one where he just blew
him out the water yeah he was way past
his exactly so I was like Dude that
[__] sucks so to me it's Max Holloway
2 volkonoski one but
um he beat the the former like Max
Hollow was supposed to be the
pound-for-pound best fighter in the
world and local gospel beating three
times in a row so that just goes to see
show how great he is but crazy [__]
fight I went back home I started Shadow
Boxing in my garage and I threw up
yeah so we had a load the motherload of
Crane Barbecue that night and you go
home and just work your ass off because
I was also [__] high as [__] yeah
like okay yeah okay sorry about that
you I I passed you a little joint and
then you took one hit and you're like
all right that's good I'm like hey man
it's puff puff pass let me just take
another so I took two hits and that was
fine it was the third one yeah it came
back to you yeah the third one is the
one that put me into the second Universe
where I was a UFC fighter yeah so we ate
so much so we have a buddy named Robin
right and there's a difference between
people who are Foodies and then fat
asses
we are fat asses dude like we Robin has
coined this term grazing which
essentially what happens is we bring
like an absorbent amount of food every
time so almost every weekend we meet up
yeah and we watch UFC fights together
and so Robin got this thing called a uh
uh like it's a Japanese pinchotan um
charcoal grill right so pinchotan is a
hardwood charcoal like Japanese hardwood
charcoal uh it lasts for like six seven
hours and you could just Grill
consistently but when you do that with
people who aren't Foodies and are fat
[__] we just eat for six to seven hours
straight we had like 10 plus pounds of
meat yes yeah and it just it was just
cycling through the grill and short rib
we had uh Ed brought over some rib eye I
brought over
um wagyu beef short plate
um some hanger steak somebody else
brought these uh redneck clams Robin dry
age two Whole pork bellies two whole
which was already like six pounds yeah
right and then we had Korean panchan on
the side we had uh
is a Korean uh military stew yeah it was
um something that was developed after
the war we had a lot of American rations
and then we used what we could canned
beans spam all this other stuff American
cheese little franks sausages yeah and
you make this [__] [__] delicious
dude we ate that and then we were so
[__] high and brought these peanut
butter cookies from Vons and then we
started growing we put them on the grill
we're so high we're like oh [__] the
fight's starting we're trying to pick it
up and the whole thing came out a
crumpled mess and then we still ate it
it's delicious
oh gosh so I you know we're we're hyped
from the fight we're watching all this
stupid [__] we're watching UFC one like
the very first fight ever ball grabbing
him ball punching yeah and then I go
home and then for some reason I'm like
you know what I was inspired I'm like I
could be a fighter yeah I could have
gone through UFC one yeah so I go home I
hop in the side of it like doing like a
weight drop type oh no oh sweat the [__]
out I come out I start Shadow Boxing
like in my mind I probably think I look
really good I do not
and so I play Shadow Boxing and then I
stop and I go
I think okay I'm fine like I'm I'm a
fighter I'm not gonna throw up so I
continue
oh God right and then the thing that did
me for some [__] reason because I saw
yair Rodriguez I threw a freaking Toyo a
spinning heel kick right that did me at
it I [__] yeah you just get like all
nauseous
and I [__] ratted that I [__] Yak
oh God right out the door no I ran into
the bathroom I made it to the bathroom
but dog it was the dumbest thing ever
and I just remember the next day waking
up like you're so [__] stupid like
who the hell do you think you are man
you can't even run a mile straight
without crying man well at least you're
not feeling all the effects of just like
meat hangover right now because since
you threw it all up I had like seven
pimples oh [__] because we were just
sitting there grilling yeah this smoke
was just getting right in your face that
oil was just going right in your eyes
and then uh even this pants I have
permanent oil stains on it and I just
washed oh holy [__] yeah but we had a
dry aged Port too so Robin took these
pork slabs and just left it in the
fridge open in there and he left it out
for a week yeah and so what that does it
reduces the moisture in your pork belly
so it's number one dries out the skin a
little bit or the surface of the meat
and the second thing it does it
condenses it gets rid of a lot of the
water so it it um the my art reaction
happens a lot faster right so when we
put it on the grill it was like brown
and crispy it was so [__] so good
um yeah but anyways enough of that
[__] fat ass talking this ain't
[__] dude yeah
um people wanted us to talk about the
last of us right yeah and I gotta tell
you this right now
I'm somebody who just I don't know why
but when somebody says a show is really
good I feel like 60 of the time to 70 of
the time it's not as good as people say
it is right right and so I avoided
watching The Last of Us because it was
based off of a game and typically what
I've seen from a lot of things that are
adapted from something else it's not
going to be that good yeah like Resident
Evil
you know zombie video games turn into
movies they do that a lot and they're
just terrible that's exactly what I was
thinking yeah a Resident Evil is not a
good adaptation right and this is what
it kind of felt like so I just avoided
the last of us but everybody and their
mom was talking about it and I watched
the first episode like a quarter of it
and I was like okay this might be decent
and that's all I knew yeah the show yeah
well when I asked after I finished the
first episode I was like okay this is
something else man yeah this is crazy
um
this show is so [__] intense in the
best way possible right and I think what
I like about the last of us and we'll
probably break down every episode as we
go on with this uh up to this point is
up at five episodes yeah it's like they
do such a good job of making you feel
things are okay and then quickly
reminding you like look this is an
apocalypse yeah this place is Bleak yeah
this is a [__] and they do that so
[__] well because I I'm watching the
characters and obviously you have a
Pedro Pascal like he's amazing every
actor and actress in this show is so
[__] good great great so [__] good
I think most of them they're all like
theater trained actors oh yeah that's
the difference man and I've talked about
this a lot where when we when we watch a
lot of shows and we're seeing a lot of
new actors that are coming in and I
think sometimes with the idea of like
representation we we are looking for
faces and characters rather than we're
looking at the skill behind the actors
right and I think that's like the the
biggest hurdle that we have to go
through as
um Asian Americans right now in film is
that we're seeing a lot of these people
who want to make films none of them are
really trained actors though yes yes
right and I'm saying this because some
of these people are peers like I've seen
them and they don't
I'm not saying they don't care about
acting right they do care about acting I
think they want to make movies yes but
then they haven't that's like you gotta
Source your actors yeah yeah the the
craft of a lot of these people who are
actors are not that great this is me
included right yeah um I don't think
these people live or die for acting and
the craft and so when you see them act
you could tell like it's very
very rudimentary it's very basic even
when you go back to old television shows
um these
CBS
um [__] what do you call it the you
know the those old superhero shows like
small villages oh right right it's the
writing's terrible and some of these
actors aren't great but I could tell
like as the show went on they're acting
on better and better and better and
they're just better at this they're
better at delivering shitty [__]
lines and so
when I look at shows like the last of us
I just go there's [__] levels to this
dude like they're so good who is it so
let's talk about the first episode right
so what I really like about the show the
first episode is the timeline and what
it said right so the very opening scene
right it was like 1968 they're on a talk
show and they start talking about oh
what could devastate the human
population
and we're we're living in 2023 now right
and we just lived through a pandemic and
then the guy says a pandemic which we
can all relate to as an audience right
and we understand what it could do but
it's like the other guy's like but it's
not going to ruin the world right and
that's something we also understand
and then he starts talking about [__]
fungus you know cordyceps
and if you've watched planet Earth and
like it's on YouTube and [__] too have
you seen how fungus kind of infect
insects yeah so and take over their mind
when I said that number one I go through
really weird rabbit holes yeah online
especially when it comes to Nature right
because obviously who doesn't follow
nature as well yeah you know but um
there is this one fungus that controls
insects like you'll see
let's say I don't know the exact insect
but there was like a clip of this thing
that looked like a cockroach it's like
the heads caved and it's dead and when
you see it just walking the [__]
zombie yeah it's the weirdest [__] ever
and the it's mostly ants apparently so
like
the uh the fungus will uh
uh explode or whatever and the pores
will spread out and then it gets amongst
the insect population mostly ants and
then it's so weird that those little
tentacle things come out of the ant's
mouth you know oh it's real yeah freaked
me the [__] out they're so [__]
disgusting yeah that was so disgusting
our infected that [__] comes out of
their mouths and they're controlled and
they get and they go into the colony to
infect more ants right but that's here's
a cool thing yuck yeah it's [__]
gross but the cool thing is there are
like I don't know if it's Warrior ants
or worker ants like just smarter ants
who see that it's infected and they'll
take it down and drag its ass way out of
the colony to just die right and what
they do is like after a while there's
stages of it where they start losing the
entire autonomy and they have no control
and they go up a branch and then they
clench onto the this little twig right
and then they'll die but the fungus
takes over their body and then you can
see it grow this [__] horn out of its
head
in order and then it just
shoots more spores out to get more
zombie insects so that's a real thing in
nature just [__] disgusting nature is
ridiculous yeah and you know Joe Rogan's
high ass always talks about nature and
[__] right and I'm always thinking this
[__] guy is high out of his mind and
then you know I start seeing some of the
clips that he's talking about and now
I'm scared to go outside yeah yeah dude
like the way people like romanticize
nature and animals
it's really odd because nature is nature
right the things that we see from
animals and creatures or whatever is
seen through a very small lens because
we're seeing it through like zoos and
you know they're trying reservations
exactly sanctuaries so you gotta save
these animals
it's like actually nature wants to kill
you I see a woodpecker just eating the
brains of another person
like the idea I'm like this Woody
Woodpecker what is he doing cannibalism
like lions eating leopards like unusual
acts in order for them to survive
they'll do anything dude and then hyenas
just eating animals through the ass yeah
because it's the easiest way to wait
while they're alive while they're alive
the [__] craziest thing ever what is
this [__] dude so I mean I also saw the
the thing where it was another type of
I'm not sure if it was a fungus but
there's like a parasite that gets into
slugs and they'll go up on branches and
they'll extend out
I hate that [__] yeah
and then just so a bird will come and
eat it so the bird will [__] it out
somewhere else and it'll reproduce or
some [__] like that oh it's [__]
disgusting dude yeah so all in all like
everything else in nature is trying to
kill us and humans we do literally live
in a type of Utopia where we're safe
from nature we are the apex predators
yes yes and that's that's another thing
that's an interesting thing to bring on
is
um because we became apex predator so
fast because of fire like we just jumped
the line to become Apex there's a long
line of other predators that are apex
predators but because of that
um if you look at lions and other Apex
Parts they have no fear yeah yeah humans
we have anxiety we have depression we
have fear and that's because we jump the
line to Apex dude that makes so dude I
saw this I'm not sure this is a side
track but we are so sidetracked by the
way I go ahead there was this like a
video of this guy
for some [__] is this dude in Africa and
he's like [__] around with this lion
yeah and like sticking his finger in the
cage and the Lion's getting pissed right
guess what he does grabs his [__]
finger and tears It Off what I don't
know why he was doing that but he was
just [__] around with a lion like
showing that oh I could I could pet this
line and the line is literally trying to
bite his finger off and it just flips
his head grabs his finger and it just
strips
and So speaking of that too so you know
how there's like these parks in Asia
where there's monkeys just run around
right did you see that video of a guy
trying to feed a little monkey something
and the monkey crawls up his shoulder
right
then it grabs a piece of his hair and
he's like oh [__] he's trying to fight
it like and then the monkey just tears
his [__] scalp off [__] that not just
some strands of hair it just went
[__] ripped off I'm telling you don't
[__] with nature right that's why I
never want to go to those monkey
sanctuaries in Thailand I keep seeing
videos of people trying to give them
food and they go [__] you I'm taking
your soul I'm not I'm taking your baby
have you seen that monkey on a
motorcycle dude try to kidnap a baby
what the [__] was that yeah yesterday
it's just this baby in Asia sitting on a
stool
dragging this baby off we're gonna make
Last of Us season like ten because
monkeys on motorcycles kidnapping babies
did somebody train that monkey who
[__] knows what the [__] man like
they skipped the Stone Age they skipped
making tools like I'm riding motorcycles
and I don't understand
it's it's really hard to Fathom how
strong [__] primates and monkeys are
they are [__] strong we are weak we
are the weakest primates in all of
mammalian or whatever the [__] the
animal kingdom yeah they that tiny
little [__] monkey that has to be I
say at most 15 pounds yeah dragging a
child like it's nothing and the kid is
like like that's like what the [__] is
happening there was a there was also
this other video of or it was a story
about somebody who was living with a
chimpanzee for like knew a chimpanzee
for a while and then I don't know what
happened exactly but basically long
story short this lady who was either a
wildlife Wildlife conservationist
the long story short of the chimp ripped
her face off he ate her face ate her
[__] face and her fingers and her toe
like ate all these extremities like
and she lived
you [__] lived okay yeah that's the
scariest part that's just like nah nah
you're right but don't [__] with chimps
don't get chimps as pets dude they're
they are literally jacked for no reason
yeah they are if you shave the chimp
down body oh yeah uh when you see Apes
with alopecia
they're like holy [__] they look like
Brock Lesnar yeah I would not want to
give him hugs
people love giving them hugs ever since
I I you know saw those articles and I
kept reading about stuff like that and
then I see these videos of these people
who live with chimps their whole life
and since they were little babies and
they see them they come up and they hug
them and they're super happy I'm like
dude yeah I get [__] nervous I don't
know man yeah even the diseases like
thing part like or who knows ticks fleas
and [__] yeah I don't know chimps can I
I just picture chimp just grabbing my
spine and ripping it out of my body
because I feel like that's they could
literally do that yeah let's go back to
the last of us okay yeah that was a big
big Segway
yeah nature wants to kill you yeah and
okay so what he says is like oh it can't
affect us now because they're depicting
it in 1968. and but he's saying but in
the future say like the climate warms
then yes they can these fungus can
um evolve and then start in fact
affecting humans too and then so in this
sci-fi World they say as the climate
change then got warmer into the year
2003 it infects the population because
it's a little bit non-linear in its
storytelling
um because in this beginning of the
second episode they also showed the Thai
scientist that whole part that was also
really good too
um I don't know if I'm jumping ahead but
then just chronologically saying how
these things came about like the
mushroom or the fungus started going
into grains and rice and all of our food
supplies first that's why it was just
because they're like an effort who was
the young the young black actress the
kid
who Pedro Pascal was I don't know her
name but she is [__] good dude yeah
she is so damn good man that first the
first uh part of that episode where we
get to know her and how beautiful she is
as a soul you know as a daughter
and like she helps her neighbors she
loves her father and she gets this
birthday present with the watch and all
that and we fall in love with her and
then [__] goes down and you see you know
what and I already knew from the jump
when I saw that old [__] grandma in
that corner I was like she's gonna do
some [__] some weird [__] right but oh
and so if you pay attention to they
offer her cookies she's like no no
that's right so that's why I'm saying
this the fungus got into the Wheats and
the grains and all of that so people who
are eating certain foods are getting
infected and so she refused to eat the
cookies and and then the grand they were
feeding it to the grandma you know what
the funny thing is when I saw that [__]
I'm like damn I would have been infected
yeah
cookies and I want to put that [__] on a
grill yeah cookies 17. oh no wonder in
the future there's no fat people right
all the fat people died first they're
all on keto
dude no braids you want to survive this
apocalypse you got to get on keto yeah
everybody's all fit yeah beyond belief
but
it's it's kind of crazy because
you know they like I said the show does
a really good job in showing love unity
um just kind of developing like the
emotional aspect of like relationships
with people really well and what they
mean to each other exactly and then you
see the whole world just go to [__] and
then things have to shift really [__]
fast and I think like the
they're also showing like how shitty
humanity is when it comes to survival
yeah yeah
um especially when it came to that scene
with the soldier where he receives the
call and so basically long story short
the whole world is going to [__] right
because everybody is turning into these
zombies people don't know who's a zombie
or not so everybody's so scared that
they're just killing each other they're
just killing everybody in fact they're
not it's the safest bet it's just to
kill everyone yeah right if you're not
affected most likely they are so just
kill them because in the in the opening
the of the scene the in Thailand
um the Thai scientist does the autopsy
is so [__] creepy and
um they asked the military ask or like
okay what do we do there's 14 missing
people and you can see just her face
just go like it's over yeah and she says
bomba yeah just bomb this bomb [__]
everybody yeah can I go home I need to
be with my family right and she like she
knew it's [__] yeah it's [__] and so
in and when we see it back in our main
character's perspective that [__] the
world's falling apart planes are falling
out of the sky
um everyone's just pandemonium and
they're trying to get away
um Pedro Pascal is Joel he and his
brother are a pretty solid team but in
that first episode we see them get split
um
in all the chaos his daughter twists her
ankle and he's carrying her
and they run away from one of these
zombie things
and a soldier saves them
but he's like hey we're not infected she
just has a twisted ankle and he gets the
soldier gets the phone call and it's
such chaos it's like it doesn't matter
if they're infected or not kill him and
he points their gun and he shoots
and then we see Pedro Pascal's hit two
and then Tommy saves and he kills the
soldier
and then we see his daughter was hit oh
like and you're just like oh [__] that
[__] wrecked me dude yeah and it's
amazing how the show made me feel for
this girl in a matter of like 20 minutes
yeah we saw the whole first episode in
her perspective yeah yeah I mean if it
wasn't for the trailers and stuff that
showed us like she's not in the trailers
yeah for the rest of the show you kind
of saw what was coming but not like this
exactly and wow the
emotions that Pedro Pascal had to
[__] part because he's uh he's
supposed to be a hardened man you know
at least had a loving relationship but
then when she is dying it is such a
[__] bummer and then it boom clicks
dude 20 years later one of the things
that I feel like a lot of um I know for
all of you people out there who love
Korean dramas and [__] um they're really
popular on Netflix right now one of the
things that Korean shows do [__]
[__] terribly that I absolutely hate
is character motive and action never
match up they just do things just to
progress the story just to have
something to see like a character will
be like a very stoic person and then out
of nowhere he's the kindest human being
on Earth and then his actions don't only
so they could develop a love
relationship but it doesn't make sense
for the character
I hate that so much and that's why this
show I really love they do these small
little things to show who this guy is
why it happens and it continues
throughout the storyline yeah it makes
[__] sense and so
that's just one of the biggest pet
peeves if I ever watch a show and I just
see like writers put in things like oh
we need something crazy to happen so
let's just make this character do it
even though throughout the whole series
it doesn't make sense with their
character at all yeah I [__] hate
that but they do such a good job of
showing like number one like their
relationship that the relationship he
had with his daughter and how it
happened how it scars him you know over
a time of like 20 years to see who he
ends up being during this because the
next thing it cuts to is Boston
quarantine Zone and there's a kid
walking out by himself and he walks into
the quarantine Zone
they take him in and they tell him hey
you made it you're safe we're going to
feed you we're going to bathe you we're
going to close you and they do the test
and it goes burnt red
cut to Joel and test they're doing their
work they have to burn bodies and
there's that kid
and Tess doesn't want to do it Joel has
no problem picking up this kid's body
checking it so it's clear
it's clear's day like he's he's over
that [__] human life is just it's Soul
it's just Bleak so it's like his sole
motivation like seemingly when you see
him just kind of how he processes these
situations right is it's just survival
that's it he just for some reason he has
his will to live and that's all he cares
about right nothing else really [__]
matters
um later on in the show you'll see the
by the way if you haven't seen the show
already [__] get on it yeah yeah
we've never done a spoiler-free review
anyway so yeah yeah so
um there's a girl who gets bit right and
I've never played the game so I know so
this is all fascinating to me
um there's a girl who gets bit but she
doesn't turn into a [__] cordycep
zombie yeah right you see the the vice
the bite yeah but it just ends with the
scar and that's it
I know did I think test founder right no
um
so I I did play the game the game is 10
plus years old but some from what I
recall like she was in some mall like
playing around and then um yeah she gets
big or whatever and all that [__] and
then she runs back in
those are the fireflies they're the
Freedom Fighters yeah because what runs
the quarantine zone is fedra which is
the new government since the United
States collapsed and they're pretty
fascist yeah right and so they're trying
to fight for a new quarantine order
let's quote-unquote say so they found
her first so they're keeping her chained
up and safe and to keep her at a
distance and then they make her do these
tests and she does in turn within so
many days right yeah and then from there
they see her as
she's the [__] answer she's the Cure
yeah to all of this like how to fix all
that and what's happening is
um Tess
and Joel are trying to find a
car battery you know yeah to match with
the truck so they can get out of there
and they're dealing with the black
market and you can see how nothing works
within the quarantine Stone so the black
market is huge which is why they're all
fine with each other and then you see
like I said troll deals trucks to a
[__] Soldier that's right that's
right that's right yeah so it's like
okay I mean they gotta make a living
they gotta survive and you can see it's
just Anarchy because uh Tess gets beat
up by a gang who who [__] double
crossed her over the [__] car battery
that's right right and they get killed
because of some street war and all that
[__] and all that to say when Tess gets
back to Joel
um they're not like in a loving
relationship they are co-survivalists
yeah they are just there because they
they need each other like not ranging
emotionally you can see but then they
have to survive together yeah it's like
this agreement that they have right and
all of that culminates to them leading
like
them running into the fireflies of
Freedom Fighters because they both need
this car battery yeah and
as fate would have it whatever because
the car battery was trash or whatever
they both need to get to the West
they agree hey there's a an out Point
Post like Rendezvous they'll have all
supplies and
um car batteries everything you need we
need you to take Ellie the girl we need
you to take her there right and
as they do they go throughout the night
they get caught by the same soldier that
um Joel deals drugs too but this time
soldiers are like nah [__] this I'm
turning you in right and then when he he
points a gun and when he does that Joel
gets triggered and he goes Wolverine
berserk mode yeah on the [__] Soldier
yeah and then in that chaos they see
that they see that she's bit right and
that's the end of episode one yeah yeah
yeah yeah the what the scene where
um test was captured I [__] love that
scene because number one it just showed
how much
there's no emotion in anything it's like
yeah you got me you [__] me up but
she's like still alive hey you [__] me
up whatever it's even I just like [__]
it like we all just want to live and
he's like no no no no like you're gonna
happen because actually I don't give a
[__] all right yeah like it's all good
let's just move on from this [__] right
no zero emotions she's not begging for
her life she's not sitting there um
trying to like emotionally get to them
so she could survive she's just like
look these are the facts right things
happen it's an apocalypse you're gonna
do what you do whatever you got your
[__] move on who the [__] cares yeah
let's just let's just get the [__] out
of here and that's what we were saying
all that that whole [__] like side
thing we had about nature trying to kill
us shows what it does to us yeah right
in that like what it does to our
humanity and our emotions for each other
when we all got to look out for
ourselves you know and then the way you
know when you're in Anarchy or like a
um wartime or anything every government
will turn fascists everyone damn well it
always does when the show progresses and
we're going to kind of go towards this
where the uh basically they have what's
the young girl's name Ellie so they have
Ellie right number one that long little
girl that young girl she could act her
ass off she's lady Mormont Game of
Thrones the little girl yeah that's her
when she was like I don't know 12 at the
time 11. I had no [__] idea yeah
that's the HBO connection that's why
she's on the show well that little girl
[__] yeah good I mean she looks great
[__] okay that makes sense then yeah
yeah so she's killing it right
so much attitude so much sass or
whatever and like you don't like her
yeah she's not likable not at all she's
[__] annoying yeah I mean which you
know from a viewer perspective it makes
me like her yeah that's the point kind
of thing right like they like why would
Joel why would if Joel doesn't even like
her why the [__] does he need to take
her out west that kind of thing right
and so like there's these moments too
where they're walking around they're
having conversation and like they're
doing a good job of like I think
explaining the world right because as
they're going through these areas
they're explaining why they can't go
through it and they also actually
explain it to the young girl because
she's a kid she wasn't alive forever
that's a great way to do Exposition
exactly because she's she had a bad
education and he'll keep saying didn't
you go to school and she goes to federal
school yeah and then Joel opens up about
what it used to be like when she's like
oh you still you know uh play this game
or do you what were airplanes like that
kind of thing and then he explains how
everything went down kind of thing so
that was
like I guess it's called the walk and
talk which is a good way to do
Exposition and a lot of dramatic shows
like is you show them walking and you
show an environment while they talk it
keeps the the viewers engaged yeah if
they're just sitting there and talking
it's a bit tougher to get it going if
they're walking then we see progression
and so that's I was like this is [__]
great storytelling like visual
storytelling great yeah plus and like
for me too for somebody who hasn't who
doesn't know anything about the game it
was very necessary for me right yeah and
because it wasn't like these status
shots of just going back in time right
and for example when they when they went
through the building and they you know
they had to explain why it's [__]
dangerous like listen and they were kind
of arguing back and forth like listen we
shouldn't go in here
um obviously because
mushroom people like dark areas they go
up to the top and they see a bunch of
these zombies just huddled together
right and they're like yo what the [__]
why are there so many now but those
those small little explanations didn't
take me out of it I didn't have to sit
there and listen to this long story they
just got to the point like this is what
it is the kid understands and they move
on yeah so they still even within the
exposition there isn't these like really
warm weird sappy moments it's just it's
still in the idea of I got the
information [__] it let's move on yeah
so they kind of keep it within the theme
of this is still survival even in their
storytelling which I really really do
appreciate because yeah it's like okay
let's move on let's see what's gonna
happen next
um fast forward to they had this crazy
fight scene with these the clickers the
[__] mushroom vagina or yeah like
labia face people [__] disgusting
yeah such an intense scene right
a quick quick uh side note um the reason
why I played last of us a long time ago
is I have this friend named Derek Espino
he works at Sony video games yeah and
he's a senior sound designer and when I
first got a PlayStation 3 I asked him yo
what game should I play and he just
recommended all the games he made which
were uh all the Uncharted series The God
of War series and they also they also
made the same Studio made thousands of
us yeah yeah and so he got me into that
he made those noises those clicking
noises oh my God he invented those
noises and I just want to drop that a
shout out to Derek that is creepy as
[__]
um but yeah they get into a whole
scuffle with that you know classic
zombie TV show fight but they get out of
it okay right
um but as soon as they get to the
Rendezvous they see everyone's dead
right and they've been infected and they
all pretty much killed each other but
there was an interesting thing that also
happens in nature you know the do you
know Nature has its own internet
so every Forest system right like every
tree actually communicates with each
other it's like hey I need some more
sunlight this way or blah blah whatever
the way it kind of moves branches
there's a communication system that is
there because of fungus
fungus is deep down in the ground and
within its root systems they connect oh
so that's what they meant and that's
where they grabbed the whole thing of
like yeah if you tell if one thing
happens here they'll know they'll know
what they communicate through their
fungus Roots there's a lot of research
for this yeah yeah the game or the show
yeah so
that's exactly what happens at the
Rendezvous Viewpoint you see some Vines
and like fungus Vines touching one dead
guy
or he was alive for a moment and they
shot his head
and then it alerted all of the big group
of zombies that were packed together and
they come running and then that's when
they have to move right and Tess reveals
like because she's freaking out yeah so
she's losing her composure she goes no
it has to be here it has to be here and
then the little girl she was like you
got bit Yeah holy [__] you're a bit yeah
yeah and then she sees the bite this is
a scene that I actually really really
enjoyed too and it's you know I don't
think it's very common that I give a
show so much praise
but even something small like this right
where I I don't know why my mind
automatically goes to oh I feel like
this is what's going to happen because I
think there's certain tropes that a lot
of television shows do that they don't
have to do per se but it's just like
everybody else does it so why not so
clearly at this point I've already
assumed
um as a viewer that she's going to
sacrifice herself but the way that she
sacrificed herself was done really
really well she has this lighter and
it's it's giving me anxiety yeah because
she can't [__] light it yeah right
and you see all these zombies just spill
in like crazy until one of them notices
her and slowly this zombie starts to
inch towards her yeah and she's sitting
there trying to light this thing and it
almost feels like she's about to give up
and as it gets close to those little
[__] is going in her mouth and I
wanted to throw up and then finally it
lights yeah and then she drops it
explodes [__] everybody well we gotta
take about take about talk about her
coming to that decision too because like
we just said earlier she doesn't give a
[__] oh that's right yeah but why why
did she turn it um in the second episode
she was ahead of Joel because she was
like she is
like the answer yeah she could change
all of this like it it gave Tess some
hope like I can start giving a [__]
again yeah and then she does she starts
giving a [__] she starts caring and she
starts she she sees the this purpose
that she must fulfill it by taking Ellie
out west
Joe's not convinced you know but for
Tess because she believes now and
there's something to give a [__] about
she's she's convinces
Joel you need to take her you need to do
this and she sacrifices our life because
she believes in it
and when we are getting into the third
episode now
it opens with they need
um they need that car battery still
right yeah well Joel has a contact his
friend bill
and they're on their way to go find Bill
and then it cuts back to 2003 in Bill's
perspective
and this guy it opens up he's in his
basement not even basement a
sub-basement of his basement and he's a
doomsday prepper yeah right dude it's
like he was waiting for the world to end
I this this was the episode that
actually made me really really like this
show yeah right no that's this episode
went so viral that everyone started
tuning in oh really yeah yeah this is
that then it makes sense because for me
I mean we could talk about a lot of
things about this one like episode three
do you want to talk about historic
television historic television emotional
roller coaster dude and
number one we you know I mentioned uh
representation right and there's
representation outside of just
um ethnicities right there's like
sexuality like you find out that bill is
gay right and not only is he gay when
you look at him he doesn't look like the
typical gay dude no right his mannerisms
or what what like TV typically portrays
of a gay male right for example if
you've seen this terrible show called
partner track that got canceled thank
god
um the worst [__] show I've ever seen
in my [__] life yeah and they have
you know I think one of the biggest
complaints
that a lot of people had in my personal
Circle that were gay or are gay were
like who the [__] is this random
flamboyant gay lawyer it's a caricature
caricature of a gay person right which I
do think a lot of you know just from
like okay I have like two friends who uh
they're like they're like my my uh gay
antennas he's like two gay homies from
Sacramento and they just like dude what
the [__] is this [__] right and
everybody has a different opinion of
that what I liked about this show was
and I think this is what I like about
representation is when you have people
exist in this world as if
they're just regular people yeah they're
them dealing with this [__]
apocalypse yeah and like they are gay
yeah and you know what I mean which is
how life is or how it should be yeah
right so it's the idea of normalizing
something in a way that's very natural
and organic right
that they this show did such a great job
of it and I think a lot of people now
have an issue of representation when
they try to shove it down people's face
rather than letting it exist the way
that it should be yeah right and they
did such a good job with [__] bill
when when Bill
so just to talk about the show so Bill
he's like this uh Doomsday prepper right
and he's really [__] good at this
Nick Offerman yes also known as Ron
Swanson on Parks and Rec he is that
character that Midwestern Stern stoic
like not emotionally outwardly but as an
actor that's amazing that that's just
thick not being an emotional person but
we'll get to the rest of the episode
where oh my God it comes out but it's
what you see [__] funny that you
would say that Ron Swanson in this
character I'm cracking up already right
it practically is possible yeah yeah
he's he's going out this is his mother's
home right that he lives in everybody is
[__] he's been prepping for this [__]
since day one yeah right because he's a
doomsday prepper goes into the Home
Depot dude he goes wild goes
free-for-all he gets a boat he's living
his [__] dream right barrels of
gasoline aging beef yeah dude doing
everything right because nobody for the
longest time
at this point you don't know he's gay
yet right
um one of the things he makes
extravagant meals maybe that was a
little bit
that was the thing right you see him do
like this filet with this like um this
bordele sauce these vegetables that he
grew it's this amazing [__] meal and
then
the part that cracked me up was he turns
on his security cam and you see this
zombie and he's walking up trips to
Marcus blasting that you think it's
supposed to be a serious scene I'll
never get tired of that yeah
he's enjoying it he's enjoying the Doom
station yeah and then um it's been four
years now him him by himself four years
surviving and then you
um he's built a [__] perimeter in his
neighborhood he's got a whole acreage to
himself so he's fine and
um
he gets a like a alarm Bells like
notification he has an intruder someone
fell in one of his traps it's a big hole
in the ground and
it's a you can see it online it this
particular scene went like viral too or
whatever like it was part of their ad
campaign it's when they first meet he
needs uh it's his name Frank yeah and
there's another man down the hole he
doesn't trust them he doesn't you know
he's obviously super paranoid of him
but he convinces him hey I'm hungry like
I won't bother you just I just need you
know a meal so he Bill agrees
mixed extravagant rabbit meal right and
he has a bottle of [__] Caymus like
it's just I was looking at the food I'm
like damn how maybe we could yeah maybe
I want to live with this guy like I want
to go survive with you yeah
but the guys you know he's washing up
he's showering they're sharing this all
right he gives him a hot shower too
right yeah and you could tell like bill
is so uncomfortable right but you don't
really know why and then in the this is
this was kind of funny too it's just him
playing the piano and singing and then
obviously this other guy who is gay he
just goes well not obviously at this
point but he just goes he's gay in my
[__] playing show tunes yeah but that
[__] kind of made me laugh that's where
it was starting to come I was like hmm
he might be getting a Game
Stop yeah he doesn't like the boys yeah
he's like ruining the song for him yeah
the funny thing is like in my mind when
I was watching the scene I was like
David don't don't just assume he's gay
yeah right he's like you know you don't
don't assume it and then all sudden yeah
yeah but you got to kind of see
it was like it was so endearing and cute
yeah like Bill gets on and he starts
singing the song in the way he likes
obviously and then uh Frank
he asks if there's girl he's like no
there's no girl there never was he goes
I know I know and then they lean in for
the kiss and Frank is like crying and
he's like what's your name and it's just
like
you know it didn't even matter there was
gay to me at that point like it was such
a beautiful scene honestly like they
were so starved for connection this is
that thing of
how
the show does such a good job of showing
Humanity right in the worst way possible
and the best way possible what I got
from the build character is that I think
he enjoyed
the world disappearing because he was
never allowed to be himself you know
what I mean yeah whether and I don't
know I don't know if this is done in the
writing but I'm assuming because he's
like in this country bumpkin ass area
him coming out as a gay man it's not
something that you're supposed to do and
even when he was living with his mom or
whatever else he had to hide his
identity right right when this whole
world went to [__] he didn't have to
hide his identity he's a [__]
doomsday prepper and you know he's never
been allowed to share the the fact that
he's gay yeah and especially with
another gay man right and so it was
liberating for him yeah and that part
just made me it was making me super
[__] emotional right and mind you
years ago I saw Brokeback Mountain
couldn't do it you know you know
Brokeback Mountain was [__] intense
though yeah this is just the a
relationship just a loving relationship
that you're seeing start to Bud cool
thing about this is I mean they get in
the bed they [__] or whatever what right
that was a little uncomfortable for me
heterosexual males was a little hard
but beyond that what I like about this
once again they're showing humanity and
they do it so naturally is that they
fast forward a time and now they're
[__] fighting yeah
he's like I loved it they like they're
fighting because he wants friends their
their banter is really endearing the
whole thing with the government isn't
Nazis like yes they are like okay they
are now but like
um I mean it shows a character who they
are but what is what is Frank really
want it's like can I spruce up the house
can I build a garden can we have some
people over right it's like you ha you
built all this like can I build some of
it can it be mine too give me something
to live for yeah right and then you see
like like Bill being I guess I don't
know efficient or fragment is like you
know we don't need Paint you know we
don't need flowers and all that [__] but
he relents and which helps us see their
relationship grow and
uh you see we see that Frank has been in
connection with Tess right and that and
he says hey I'm bringing some friends
over we're gonna have friends and then
they have this like Garden lunch and
it's such a nice looking scene in this
Bleak world yeah this is concocted
I mean there's a little funny dialogue
too because he's like oh you know builds
a paranoid schizophrenic and he's like
I'm not schizophrenic but he won't deny
his paranoid yeah
but it has a very
interesting setup for us to see how Joel
and Bill connect they're the same type
and the same ilk of people in this
[__] Bleak future
but they both understand what they're
you know doing in order to survive and
then we see that hey man I can get you a
better fence out there to keep you
protected and you know they'll stay in
communication they kind of more or less
warm up to each other and then they also
see that their purpose that they have
I want to say I guess in the as the
masculine aspects of their relationship
that they are trying to
they're trying to keep tests and Frank
alive that's both of their purposes
essentially and then we see that Frank
went so bill has a [__] Arsenal he's
got guns and Guns and racks and racks of
guns and Frank trades a gun for some
strawberry seeds and we see this
beautiful moment where they have
strawberries for the first time in how
many years that was a beautiful scene
yeah and then Bill Giggles yeah a little
school girl when he eats the strawberry
uh and he's like yeah
and and like we see like man they have
hope yeah these people have built
something where it [__] works because
we saw the quarantine Zone we see
[__] Freedom Fighters and fascists
and everyone's out for each other's next
and then we see this beautiful aspect of
this Bleak future
cut to
um a firefight
outside and then
um which is what Joel uh warned him
about yeah there's people what are
called Marauders yeah right they're just
scavengers yeah yeah try to take their
[__] but Bill of course like booby traps
his whole fans [__] him up but he gets
shot
and in that scene we're seeing like
uh build seems to be dying on the table
he's like call Joel call Joel Joel will
know what to do
and Frank's just talking to him like a
medic he's just keeping him as like sure
yep that's what we'll do and he's just
treating his Moon Fade to Black and it's
10 years later
and Frank is in a wheelchair it seems he
has Ms or ALS they're old now
and it's just beautiful because it's
quiet and they're old and
you know they're just doing home life
you know they're and
um
Frank is painting a portrait of bill and
it's kind of getting [__] up I mean
it's still beautiful painting in itself
but you could see how Frank
seems to be giving up yeah on his life
in that moment and then in the next
morning Frank tells bill this is my last
day yeah and that's when they're sitting
on the couch and Bill is
that the emotions are coming out yeah
Nick Offerman
breaks our hearts the way he just
doesn't want to go through with this
plan well that was the crazy thing where
everything felt
he was doing everything just as a
survivalist right because he talked
about you know he joked about his
paranoia and how he approaches
everything is very pragmatic
um that strawberry scene I feel like
that's when his Humanity came out he
goes there's something to live for
outside of just surviving right and he
shares this like this loving moment with
his partner
and you could see the the connection of
the relationship isn't just oh you're
you're somebody that could help me get
rid of this loneliness during this whole
pandemic that that we're all going
through it's I love this person and
we're in this loving world and there's
something to live for outside of just
surviving and then you see it affect him
when he finds out the his reason for
living is now going to disappear yeah
that [__] was [__] yes to me and they
developed that so [__] well when they
were doing so the next thing that you
guys see is the dinner scene right so it
kind of goes back to they they have
their beautiful last day they get new
clothes and stuff they they do a small
wedding and then they have their dinner
yeah and they they go to the scene where
they're having this dinner right which
is kind of an Ode to the first time the
first time they met they had the same
meal the same meal and everything else
they have that beautiful bottle of
Caymus they're pulling out the wine and
then you see him put in whatever that
chemical is that's going to kill him and
he puts it into his drink and give it to
him and he Downs it well which you don't
know which I kind of assumed is that he
already put it in his wine as well yeah
and he told him like you were the reason
why
I lived for this long he said you are my
purpose which is crazy right you see
this guy who's this stoic human being
have feelings and emotions and this
person who was his partner brought that
out of him yeah and that whole
relationship scene [__] wrecked me
dude like I I was wrecked when I when I
when I even though I knew that they were
both going to die like I assumed as a
viewer it killed me man because it
started putting me into a perspective of
okay what would have happened if I was
in this situation right like if the only
person that gave me Santa let's say
Mariel and I somehow survived right and
I'm the crazy person right and I know
that Mariel has to die I was like would
I want to be around for the next 10
years by myself yeah I don't think so
yeah what's the point what's the purpose
yeah like he he was going to lose his
purpose so insane yeah and so he was
happy to give up his own life as well
like hey I did everything we did it and
they did it like nobody else seemed on
Earth seemed to have done it yeah and it
did it so well and for us we can accept
yeah they can die in peace they got to
lead the way that they wanted to which I
feel in this time is a luxury yeah it's
a [__] luxury they got to eat an
amazing [__] meal together they got
to do it with the person that they love
and they got to live to an older age
nobody else gets that in this world
except for them yeah and then so then we
cut to present time
it's like a few weeks later uh Joel and
Ellie roll up to Bill's compound
he knows the code
and long story short Ellie finds the
letter
um and Bill addresses it to Joel and in
it
as Ellie's reading it for him
um
he talks about the purpose you and I we
have a purpose on this Earth and no
[__] is gonna stop us from that
purpose and for me it's take care of
Frank and for use to take care of Tess
click the last episode test died and and
so Joel has a little mini breakdown
why
because what we did see before was like
I said Joel and Tess were Co
survivalists II and throughout this
whole episode we just saw two other cool
survivalists
just [__] do it right and they loved
each other Joel and Tess didn't seem to
love each other
in that sense because they were they're
such cynics now they're nihilists like
this whole world is [__] up
but deep down Joel did love tests yeah
yeah
and because
he was like that was our purpose your
purpose was to take care of Tesla Tess
is gone but what did tests want Joel to
do it's like take Ellie this is for real
take Ellie out west
and people miss this Joel goes back in
and he says show me arm it's like he
this guy knows yeah he says show him he
had to be sure one more time to look at
it and it's it's healing her arm's
healing
consult he accepts that fate they could
have stayed on that compound there's
plenty of food shelter running water hot
water all that [__] they could have
stayed in Bill's compound and and lived
out the rest of their lives as well but
he was like he accepts his fate he
accepts this new purpose his new purpose
is Ellie yeah you know and that's why
this whole scene was so pivotal people
say oh it was so unnecessary why do we
have to say it was such a deviation it
was like context yeah for us to see like
purpose and this is essentially the if
this was a nine hour movie This is the
first act yeah yeah yeah Joel has now
found his purpose and he is acting out
his purpose so throughout the whole show
the person that I felt feel for the most
is Joel right because his
personal mission is to not feel anything
right because he knows what it feels
like to have somebody that he loves and
have it taken away from so many times
throughout the show right it happened
with his daughter it's happening with
Tess and every time he tries to strip
himself of his own Humanity this is just
a mission yeah I don't care about you
this is a promise that I have to keep
and then every time like he starts
feeling a little bit more like a person
it gets taken away from taken away from
him and then he gets a sobering reminder
like we do this is a pot this is an
apocalypse right yeah
um later on throughout the show just to
fast forward you start to see like
Joel's Walls Start to break down right
Ellie finds that book of puns the puns
that dad jokes to yeah and it starts
breaking him down a little bit Yeah and
you know at first you don't really he
doesn't really he's not really receiving
it very well because he's kind of
ignoring her telling it like finishing
her jokes he knows like he knows these
[__] jokes or whatever right and it
just looks like a guy who's really
trying his best trying Matt to fall in
love with this child as like a father
figure yes right because I mean honestly
she's probably the same age that his
daughter was when she died yeah exactly
um
you get into the latest episode right uh
episode five well four and five could be
considered one whole episode same direct
same director yeah it could be one whole
chapter of its own story within this
larger story
um we can fast forward it basically what
it comes to is
um
the Freedom Fighters uh were they St
Louis
I can't remember yeah I think they're in
St Louis Missouri they have taken over
fedra you know they've overrun it and
the new leader is a [__] monster
where
um she's out for Revenge she has to find
this guy Henry
because he turned in her brother and her
brother was the former leader and he was
a great man and everybody loved him but
well he was taken by federal he was
murdered and that drove her to
you know start this revolution
from I didn't look it up but she looks
so familiar in her voice she's a New
Zealand actress but yeah I don't recall
where else she's from but heartless yes
heartless she kills a doctor like you
know you guys could use a doctor but
because she's so angry at how he was an
informant for Frederick she [__]
kills him she kills another room full of
informants she's she's a mom she's out
for revenge for this guy Henry for what
he did to her brother
they're a mirror image of itself because
the reason why Henry turned in her
brother was because fedra had the
medicine for his younger brother Sam's
leukemia so for him to get the
medication for Sam he had to turn in uh
whoever the old Freedom the older
Freedom Fighter was I forgot his name
but the the guy that everybody loved
and then he's like I know I did a bad
thing but like what would you do I had
to save my brother
right and you're seeing that
even in this Bleak apocalypse like
people aren't doing things pragmatically
people aren't doing things for the sake
of the commune or the quarantine zone or
anything it's like you got to look out
for yourself and my brother has to live
and she's saying my brother should have
lived yeah right and it all culminates
to this big fire fight
holy [__] like
you know there wasn't a huge Zombie
thing in in episodes three and four but
five was the [__] hole opens up on
the bottom like I said the sobering
reminder comes back right yeah because
they spent those couple of episodes
developing the relationship between
Ellie and Joel right
us as audience though in the back of our
heads we know there are zombies out
there yeah yeah yeah yeah and the way
that they did this I mean I kind of
glossed over this part too but it was
the thing that kind of took me aback was
when um
they got [__] over by those uh the
rebels right and they crashed in and
this is where you kind of they kind of
do a flashback where they they ended
this fourth episode with Joel and Ellie
waking up to Henry with the gun to his
face right and they kind of backtrack to
see how this happened but in that scene
where they were doing this fight scene
basically Joel [__] them all up
including Ellie and there was one guy
who was still alive and he was just
begging for his life and he tells Ellie
to go away yeah and in my mind I'm
thinking oh
and I kind of forgot for a second once
again because I got to see Joel's
Humanity yeah yeah and then there's that
sobering reminder this is just survival
and he [__] murder says just kills
him he's begging for his life saying
like look I just want to go see my mom I
just want to see my family you got it
we're good I'm sorry we're okay no
emotion whatsoever and [__] damn just
murdered this [__] and then it
was really great because Ellie while
she's a little [__] right and then
what we're seeing is that she's a little
[__] because how she can survive
because she is scared right and we still
see her like shed a tear but she's just
like still though like in this just
crazy this is crazy [__] she shouldn't
be exposed to this yeah um I thought
that was super powerful too and then um
do we want to get to the that last scene
where everything is just yeah chaos just
to give a little background before this
we won't go too deep into this part but
you know Henry and Joel and Ellie and
his younger brother they decided they
could use each other to kind of get free
from his zone right and so Henry is the
key to this because he knows the city
and then he needs Joel's protection
because Henry has never killed anybody
in his life right the first time he's
ever pointed a gun at somebody that was
loaded was at Joel yeah you know yeah oh
and his younger brother is Sam he's deaf
yes and that was a deviation from the
game
um apparently like they made him deaf in
the show not because of representation
for ASL and deaf peoples although that
was like a really beautiful thing
but because Sam is is more helpless he
needs Henry yeah you survive to show
that aspect like he needs like Henry to
be there
um
so
it all culminates to the lady with the
rebels they've catch up to them they
find them
and then they have this important talk
like saying like your brother's just a
he's just a kid and he's like yeah he's
just a kid kids die all the time yeah
and they have this argument like who was
more about whose life is more valuable
and this is ultimately an argument of
who do you who loves their brother more
yeah
and that's what they're arguing about
essentially it's like love like you [__]
me over no you're [__] me over kind
of thing yeah so they all basically they
thought that they were going to escape
they kind of got towards the end
the rebels have a sniper at the end
because they know that this is the exit
and they all got caught up right and so
this is where that argument is happening
because they're hiding behind a car at
this point because they dodged all these
um they were dodging basically the
sniper yeah and they're she's giving him
an ultimatum like hey
and it's not really an ultimatum it's
you make the choice on how you want to
die you know because it's not because he
was like let the kids go she goes no no
oh it's like I have the upper hand I'll
kill all of you it doesn't [__]
matter it's just how do you want to do
it you want to hide and get murdered or
do you want to come out and get murdered
yeah which one is it [__] heartless
[__] dude that woman was scary as hell
and then I don't know if you want to
call it deus ex machina because everyone
gets [__] up but the Zombies come out
of the [__] ground and a whole horde
of them and then a specific one called a
a bloater comes out oh it's that thing
was disgusting it's gross its whole body
is just [__] up and it's a giant
[__] hulking mushroom zombie and it
tears people apart literally to somebody
yeah just rips heads off and [__]
um well in the chaos fast forward they
they get out are for uh protagonists
that we're following the lady gets
[__] up by a contortionist baby zombie
oh my gosh
and the creepiest [__] and um they very
satisfied though yeah yes they get out
they get to a motel they seek shelter
and they're gonna keep heading out west
oh Ellie and Sam
they develop a relationship throughout
the whole episode and Ellie's looking
after Sam and reading stories to him
and then they're like hey we have long
road let's go to bed now and this is
kind of a good reminder too in the show
that at least a kid and she wants
friends yeah you know so she finally got
to see another kid and they they get to
kind of communicate with the way kids do
they're laughing they're having fun
there was a part in that episode too
where he looked at his younger brother
he goes I haven't heard that laugh in
ages right right and once again the show
does a great job of making you feel like
everything's okay yeah
more people together yeah it's better
than numbers to survive together
well he has a little Etch A Sketch to
communicate with where he he writes and
it was a a scene where we see Ellie is
scared all the time he lets her know and
he says he's scared because he's gonna
turn into a monster inside him right and
then he reveals that he was a bit in the
ankle
and so I'll stay up with you you know
and Fades out
Fade up Ellie fell asleep and Sam's on
the edge of the bed
checks on him and he's a zombie oh you
know what the funny thing is is like
when I saw that moment I actually
thought that he was going to be okay
that they were setting it up that he's
not yeah and that he's going to turn
around and he was all right because
Ellie cuts her hand open she says my
blood is medicine
yeah and we hope we hope oh yes that's
right yeah you know obviously this
application is so rudimentary right and
I don't think this is not how medication
is supposed to work but who knows like
this is a dystopian world this is all
made up so maybe they just need to have
blood on blood contact and it's fine hey
I I don't have HIV let me cut my home
open and put it on your own and
therefore yeah so I I don't I don't know
why I thought it would work but then
they set up the scene where he's sitting
at the edge of the bed and he's looking
out the window and that's where I felt
like they're setting it up to make us
feel that he's going to turn this up but
he's not he's going to turn around he's
going to be fine you're hoping and I I
was [__] wrong
and then you see her older brother with
a gun he snatched the gun before Joel
can get to it and he points it right at
Joel and he's like what are you doing
you're like and Sam is [__] thrashing
at Ellie and it's like taking forever
and then
Joel is just like [__] it and then he
runs for it
and Henry makes a quick decision and he
shoots his own brother
that [__] [__] wrecked me man that
was so especially because they already
prefaced it with he is the most
non-violent human being and he is
anybody and the first person he kills is
his own brother
he's like what did I do what did I do
even as this survivalist he's never even
killed a [__] zombie dude yeah and he
has to kill his old brother I did not I
mean
obviously I had a feeling he was going
to kill his brother but what happened
after is what double [__] me yeah he
ends up he can't live with this grief in
the last split moment he decides to
[__] kill himself kills himself
sobering reminder this is the world that
we're in this is the reality I mean it's
it is a mirror of I mean he did
he did what Bill did yeah except he did
it and he had to do it in the most
tragic because his purpose was gone
yeah and I think that really so um
that's the scene afterwards they bury
them in the back
and Joel takes his time
Joel takes his time and looks at these
two bodies and he looks at Ellie walking
away like
he has to protect her or that's him in
the ground too yeah if Ellie's gone then
he it's kind of a
it's no words are spoken but you can see
through his reflection he'll kill
himself too yeah yeah
which furthers like his drive and his
purpose and you kind of see Ellie Hardin
as a human being yes because she didn't
even take the time to to mourn this loss
of a friend that she's a friendship she
started developing with this young kid
and she's just like you know what [__]
it just walks off she's hardening as a
human being her emotions are starting to
to leave her yeah and you get to see
this young girl become that heartless
adult that everybody else is becoming
because you know kids tend to have this
this light about them right this
optimism and you see it with her she's
reading these these um this joke but
she's trying to make light of situations
she's trying to laugh have a good time
and then
this is that moment that you see a
change maybe her character in The Next
Episode that we haven't seen yet where
it's okay
this is a task [__] it move on don't
attach yourself to anything else yeah
it's so Bleak oh the show that's the
halfway point that's episode five I
believe that will be Nine episodes so
we'll come back after the fight the
finale yeah because at this point
like I said it's been a while since I've
seen a show I think the last show that I
liked this much was Peacemaker
Peacemaker right so it's been a hot
second man and even Mario likes her so
she doesn't really like
um gory horror films horror films I will
say this though she saw the episode with
uh with Bill and his uh boyfriend and
she was like I didn't really feel as
much as uh other people I was like man
you heartless [__]
how could you [__] not because it's
not a K drama yeah cause it's not a K
drama it's because Bill was hairy that's
why yeah she hates hair on men if those
two were like hairless hairless she
would have been completely fine
the last of Yahweh
she would have been perfectly fine man
but she doesn't like body hair on people
so when she saw those two guys these two
grizzly bears trying to [__] each other
she was like hairy people need love too
I know I think she's so used to seeing
like hairless people kind of threw her
off a little bit it wasn't any hateful
[__] it's just like oh my God they have
so much hair on their bodies it's
probably because everyone in UFC shaves
their bodies
just watch Olympic swimming oh man dude
that that episode is going to go down in
history as one of the best
like scenes in television history yeah
it's it's so good man yeah like I said
any any type of show that really kind of
we could talk about this too where I
really like trading the bus on the line
you just watched it I just watched it
because train to Busan wasn't a zombie
film it was another movie about classes
yes yeah it was so good that like the
zombie part is just the backdrop of
everything right it's about classism
it's about the relationship that he has
with the kid it's two koreas the
collective communal Koreans who share a
giga together
and then the the selfish greedy
you know
take everything that's out there it's
all mine kind of mindset that's kind of
the classism War that's happening in
Korea right right and so I I feel when
the the backdrop is the thing that you
expect the film to be about but it's
it's about something that's a lot more
deeper and a lot more interesting to
make a better film and even with this
episode it wasn't about Bill and uh
what's his boyfriend's name Frank Bill
and Frank and them finding their
sexuality right yeah which I feel that a
lot of terrible television shows will
try to use that as an agenda to get more
views yeah right that they're that part
is just a backdrop that kind of lended
itself to see the beauty of their
relationship right that is what I call
good writing and it's just so good the
writing of the show is so [__] good
and a lot of shows can tend to [__] up
things that are already there right when
we see this in Marvel films all the time
which you're gonna hear in the next yeah
yeah you know where comic books are
pretty intricate yeah right they have
character development the source is all
there it's all there but for some reason
when it goes on the screen it gets all
mangled and [__] up
um that's why I had such low hopes for
this even though I never uh played the
game where I didn't know anything about
it I'm just I have a little bit of PTSD
when it comes to adaptation yeah yeah
you see that in anime films specifically
anime live action films Jesus Christ are
so bad but there's just been a history
of bad video game adaptations
um but I think this is a big Catalyst
for Hollywood to look at and and take
video games seriously you know and take
anime seriously because what Hollywood
does is get the rights to make an
adaptation and then they get some guy
who's not even a [__] fan on the
movie to write like DBZ Dragon Ball
Evolution the guy who wrote it how to
make an apology is like I actually don't
know anything about it that's [__]
crazy you know that's why the Witcher is
really good well no well season one you
know it's it's tanking now they deviated
so far from
yeah yeah so Henry Cavill quit because
they were taping eating away yeah so
because the writers were apparently the
news is the writers hate the books it's
like then why are you on this [__]
show yeah you know so I only saw the
first season yeah well Hollywood needs a
change where I go get the source writer
get the people who made it in the first
place to be ahead of it because the last
of us the guy the showrunner the writer
the director is the guy who made the
[__] game and he's got a co-writer
director who does films that's perfect
yeah that's why it's great and he's in
charge of the changes that make it
adaptable to the screen
that's all from the video game that's
why it's so [__] solid and that just
says like oh my God there's so many
great [__] stories out there that we
can adapt finally Metal Gear Solid Mass
Effect dude all these great stories like
video games I cannot wait till somebody
because Metal Gear Solid can be such a
good [__] movie man yeah it could
it's like the Japanese Captain America
in the MCU films because that Captain
America MCU films became political
Thrillers right and that's like that's
almost it can be in that vein Metal Gear
Solid is almost like that but yeah I'm
just saying like
I wish Hollywood would just look at Last
of Us and see what exactly worked and
it's just the source material just get
down to the source because I mean who's
going to know more about this world to
basically better help the World building
than the person who created the world oh
that guy from Silver leg you know
his laptop with the flannel yeah
PlayStation 5 right like you know that
kind of [__] oh you play video games you
must know it's like it's kind of like
that it's not the same like imagine
somebody trying to do
I don't know any type of Marvel film
without knowing any of the the comic
books it would never hire them that's
why so that's the problem before Marvel
Studios came to be they were just Silo
operations of a director's vision of
what they thought the superhero should
be until you have Kevin feige coming in
building Marvel Studios he's like no
here are the rules and stipulations to
every character and what they're like
and their journey and all that and and
they had a way to regulate the Canon DC
didn't that's why this past 10 years
it's been a jumbled mess so now James
Gunn is taking over he is the new CEO of
DC Cinema he just came out with a video
where he's talking about the future
projects he's saying it's going to be
one whole cohesive Universe video games
Comics animated TV series and movies
that will be the same actors and if
they're in an animated show they'll do
the voice to like it'll be one whole
question let me say something every
actor right now just creams their pants
because they're like you're telling me
I'm gonna get paid four times over yes
exactly right that's more work you get
contracted through like 10 years like
yeah you have to be in these products
It's [__] amazing yeah well guys that
wraps up this episode of The Genius
brain podcast where we reviewed the last
of us up to episode five this was
actually really highly requested yo
um and I couldn't do it because I didn't
watch it so man I watched it I was like
let's [__] was good timing because
we're right at the midpoint they wanted
me to talk about it on on their
streaming but I'm like I can't do it
it's a little different it's a little
more intricate but um you can catch Ed
at edpark VP that is his social handles
his podcast Bible study at Momo check
that out as well a genius brain every
Sundays at 12 p.m and we'll see you all
next time peace
right now
[Music]